now that you've got a show on hbo and
then you're the head writer on saturday
live
the the amount of material you have to
come up with and then the decision has
to be made what's right for saturday
night live
and what's right for the michael che
show well it's
it's pretty easy now it's like well
almost nothing is right for saturday
night live that i'm coming up with
lately but
is that true it becomes hard to see like
because
at snl um you kind of have to set up the
you kind of have to set up everything
inside of the sketch you know there's
something that dave actually told me
chapelle actually told me this
uh when he hosted we were talking about
it and he just kind of said it
flippantly and it just kind of made the
world make sense to me
but he was talking about when he did his
show somebody he would set it up and
stand up he would set up a lot of the
sketches and stand up
and then that way the whole sketch would
just be punch lines pretty much
right and i was like that's genius but
on snl you can't really do that because
you know it's a variety show so there is
no person that's kind of
leading everything in so it's uh it's a
lot more tricky
you went to a pitch meeting at saturday
live and you said i got a great idea for
a sketch
the first the first black guy to boo
jackie robinson
and i went how did they not
make that how did they not allow you to
put that on saturday live that just
sounds funny to me
sometimes we actually try to make it and
then the audience is like
what is going on they think it's almost
a trick you know
so you know like if you know it's hard
it's hard sometimes with
like uh with the the dress audience
because we go through dress rehearsal
and then
air so a lot of times things that we
think are super funny don't make it past
the dress audience because you know the
audience is like i don't know that we
should be laughing at this the one that
didn't get on the ear
was the idea of the avengers
accidentally
kill an unarmed black teenager i mean i
think i think for obvious reasons
there's no way that's going why why not
i don't know well because a lot of times
sometimes that's something that's like
racially specific the audience is kind
of looking at saturday night live
as lauren michael's show they're not
looking at it as oh these are
this is a black writer who is making
this nuance observation or whatever so
it's
it's a little trickier you know on my
show i could get away with it because
they know it's me or dave could get away
with it you know but like on a on a
mainstream show a lot of times
even black people are a little bit like
well why are we doing that there like
what do they mean by that you know it's
a little bit more
what are you making fun of here it's we
don't really get the benefit of the
doubt for something that's
that loaded you know you love racial
humor
and here's the sketch you wrote that i
know you wrote
that i thought was so brilliant slavery
has just ended
and uh this this young black guy walks
into a
bar in this deep south and he's like hey
man hey everybody hey
get me a drink bartender like he doesn't
realize like
yes slavery has legally ended but he
doesn't realize
that things just aren't perfect yet it
was called uh 12 days not a slave
that kind of racial humor to me is where
saturday night live now can
shine because they have black cast
members and black
writers i think the diversity has helped
that show so much uh when i first got
here it was
uh just keenan and jay
were in the cast but there was no black
writers the interesting thing is
sometimes
like if i was to if i were to write or
if a black writer was to write
something that's specific to black humor
all white staff
might not get the joke so it's deemed
not funny
so it doesn't go on there but the more
black people that's in the room the more
black writers the more black casters in
the room
they'll laugh and they'll and then
you'll be like wait oh so what maybe i'm
missing something and then things that
probably wouldn't have gotten the
benefit of the doubt then we'll get it
now
it fuels an energy in the writing
session where people go oh yeah now i
get it now it's funny
and that's got to do with race and
that's got to do with gender it's got to
do with
youth that's good you know there's a lot
having that diversity in the room
makes it makes the show more diverse the
black jeopardy sketch
where tom hanks was the guest host that
sketch in particular to me
really shows off your writing skills but
i was struck by how
well tom hanks played the white trump
guy
there's a part in there where uh keenan
goes over to shake his hand
and tom like does this thing now it's
completely tom
i appreciate you saying that i like that
but like i could i would have never
thought of that you know like i think
keenan kind of just thought you know
what i'm gonna shake your hand and go
over there and tom just
literally does this and it was like it
got like one of the biggest laps of
the sketch but that's just him finding
it how does it work you write the sketch
for black jeopardy
are you then the guy who stands there on
set and produces it
when you write a sketch you kind of you
have to see it through it wasn't just me
it was it was brian tucker who came up
with the i
he came up with the idea for the sketch
but that sketch kind of worked the
entire time
it was it's interesting like black
jeopardies for whatever reason
gets people riled up so like
we'll listen to sketches under the
bleachers like we'll watch them with
with lawn for dress rehearsal
so we can get notes on it and every time
we do black jeopardy you literally
hear people stomping on the under the
bleachers
because they're so excited for the jokes
which is strange
that's why i say like these jokes can
work you know like you can still
pull them up they're just very tricky